welcome back so in the last lecture
we're starting to introduce this concept
of sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity which tell us something
about how disturbances noise and
references affect the output of the
system why and these can be represented
as simple functions of the loop transfer
function K times P so where we're going
is that we're going to actually design K
so that the loop transfer function and
the sensitivity and complementary
sensitivity have beneficial properties
for reference tracking disturbance
rejection and noise attenuation but a
little bit more useful than looking at Y
is actually looking at the error epsilon
so let's say I have epsilon equals what
is epsilon equal well it equals R minus
R minus this Y and this is kind of why
measurement okay so if I just take R
minus all of this stuff what I end up
with is okay R - all of this is identity
minus this and remember S Plus P add up
to the identity so identity - t is just
s so I'm left with the sensitivity
function times R plus well now it's -
because I'm - in all of this - the
sensitivity times my disturbance
transfer function times my disturbance -
- is the plus plus complementary
sensitivity times noise so this is
really really useful okay now we
actually have the error which is what we
want I actually don't care so much about
the value of Y I just want Y to equal R
I want epsilon to be as small as
possible and much as possible for many
disturbances and noises and references
as possible okay so I want this to be 0
for R D and T that are reasonable for my
system and so what we're going to go
through is one by one we're going to
look at what we
each of these terms to do for good
performance and we're going to look at
what we can ask them to do because there
might be we might be asking too much to
have all of these designed exactly like
what we want and one of the remarkable
things one of the great things about
control theory is a lot of the time I
can actually have most of what I want
for the reference tracking disturbance
rejection and noise attenuation without
asking for too much okay
so let's think about it first of all
what do I want epsilon to be given some
reference now you are well think about a
cruise controller if I am driving down
the highway and I'm going 60 and I
decide the speed limit changes what
happens I can go 70 now so my reference
just stepped up and it's going to be
there for a really long time okay if I
had a stop sign if I had my traffic
signs go 60 miles an hour 70 60 70 60 70
every one second I'd have to be slamming
on the brakes and hitting the gas and
slamming on the brakes and hitting the
gas and that was that's not something
that's realistic for my control system
so my reference values it's realistic
that I want good reference tracking for
a sufficiently slow change in reference
okay so I'm not going to be able to
track this reference that it's going
ridiculously fast but for low
frequencies I want good tracking okay
and so I'm going to start thinking about
these things in terms of the bode plots
of the sensitivity function and the
complimentary sensitivity function so
this is Omega and then what we're going
to have I'm going to pick I guess red
for sensitivity and what I want is for
low frequencies I want the error to be
essentially zero so at low frequencies
are I want s to be really really small
because I want to have almost no error
okay so for low frequencies whatever low
means I want s to be really really small
okay this is my magnitude of F that's
actually also what I want for
disturbance rejection okay because again
my disturbance is in a crew
controller maybe I have these rolling
hills I can't compensate for arbitrarily
fast changing terrain but if I have slow
rolling hills my cruise controller is
reasonably going to be able to keep
error small for low-frequency
disturbances
so again when disturbances for
low-frequency disturbances if s is small
I get good disturbance rejection if s is
small I get good reference tracking
because I have low error given a low
frequency change in reference now let's
make my T my complimentary sensitivity
let's make this blue okay so blue here
what do I want for noise attenuation
well any of you who have run experiments
knows that noise is generally speaking
high frequency right I have all this
fuzz on top of my signal so I don't need
T to always be small
I need t to be especially small for high
frequencies let's call this the
magnitude of T the complimentary
sensitivity and let me move it over a
little bit okay
so for low for high frequencies I want
my high frequency noise to be attenuated
okay so I want small trim this is a
transfer function of frequency plot so
I'm looking at
log of the absolute value of F and log
of the absolute value of T and so for
high frequencies I want the
complimentary sensitivity to be small
because that gives me low error for high
frequency noise and for low frequencies
I want the sensitivity to be small
because that gives me low error for
references and disturbances and because
these things have to add up to identity
to one at every frequency Omega I can't
just have s be low all the time or else
T would be big all of the time and I
can't have TB Bagle low all the time or
else s would be big all of the time and
so what happens is you end up having
this interesting crossover point where s
kind of rolled off at some point
and T also rolls off roughly at the same
point
and this is what we call the crossover
frequency or at least this is one
definition of the crossover frequency
which is where the sensitivity begins to
get large and the complimentary
sensitivity begins to get small because
remember these have to add up to one so
I can't always have both of them be
really really small if s is small T has
to be close to one if T is small s has
to be close to one but this is kind of
cool because usually reference tracking
and disturbance rejection or kind of low
frequency phenomena so I'm okay having
my penalisation on s for the low
frequencies and noise attenuation is
usually something we care about at high
frequencies so there's this sweet spot
in Omega C this crossover where I get to
choose where do I think noise is going
to start to dominate or where do I think
that disturbances are going to dominate
so if I want to have a higher
performance system if I want to be able
to track faster references and faster
disturbances then I'm going to be trying
to move this whole crossover to the
right which means I'm going to have to
have less noisy measurements first of
all okay and there's other things that
are going to have to happen so but I
need my noise to be higher frequency and
I unless noisy if I want to move this
performance to the right so I need
higher quality measurements for higher
performance that's pretty interesting
okay and you can also think about it in
terms of the output Y so you know I want
t to be big or close to one I want t to
be close to one for low frequencies for
Y to equal R that's another way I like
to think about it okay and then we can
start tying this back to the loop
transfer function so if we know that we
want s and T to look like these we can
start thinking about what we want the
loop transfer function to look like and
that's what's coming up next
thank you